did you guys see what coachella said
no oh wow okay this just came out
earlier and if you're listening to this
on a different day you probably already
know but the news came out that
coachella was going to drop
all coveted regulations and restrictions
from their festival in april
um but i don't know if
i can see a calendar in the calendar you
know it looks like april is uh
january february march two months away
and
they are already dropping all
restrictions so you don't need a
negative test you don't need a proof of
vaccine you don't need literally
anything for 150 000 people um
your thoughts barry anything
not surprised it feels like with all the
others what walmart did the same
it feels like we're heading that way
and what i think will happen is we'll
see that and then individuals will be
making their own decisions i mean i had
a couple of conversations just today
about people
another musician who canceled a local
gig he just doesn't feel right and yet
he was in a luncheon room with about 35
people
you know no mass one there's one mass so
i'm not surprised uh well
i think of it like so mardi gras is
happening right now and we've been going
to parade after parade ball after ball
and there are moments where i feel a
little
you know a little close a little tight
so i'll put the mask on and i you know
maybe it makes me feel better or
something right that's what i mean you
know but that is an open
air
open to
you know i haven't paid a ticket for it
i can just walk in and go home whatever
i want to the only thing about a
festival like this is that if you least
have a covid test or a
you know proof of vaccine at least
there's some sort of layer of protection
at least it feels like a layer of
protection you don't feel
weird about not having that
well i do
that's what i'm saying but it's a
it's an individual i think it will
become an individual
thing like you just said you feel weird
about it so you either put a mask on or
you back away or go home or whatever
um but i think the majority people are
just they're over it they're ready
they're done i'm not saying it's right
or wrong
i'm just saying that's definitely the
vibe i feel well that's that's the way
that i feel
you know i did i did everything that i
was supposed to do you know i've done
all my parts and at some point i've
gotta you know we gotta get out
as my uncle would say get out amongst
them go live um you know but it does
make me feel better when i go into a
restaurant and they're checking vaccine
cars it does make me feel better um
you know i think it would make me feel
better if there was some sort of layer
of of at least perceived precaution um
but you know
the reality is that's probably all it is
is perceived probably
yeah it's i think it's mostly theater
i mean
how many how many people did we hand our
vaccination cards to at a restaurant in
new orleans and they just like okay yeah
fine i could have handed them a you know
an uno card or something yeah they don't
really care they're just okay
you know what you say that i did it
i've had that card six seven eight
months i think i've shown it one time in
that way well you're in a different
place though
i mean but it's my place it's whatever i
understand but i don't know anybody
that city
has not acted as if covert was happening
since covet began they don't they've
never pretended like this thing was a
thing here russ has seen it
here you have to show it to get anywhere
which is strange isn't it because you're
you're in a city of disasters yeah yeah
yeah
well they're not our disasters you know
but they're disasters and you've seen
all of them everything that locust that
i can think of oh i've dated a few i um
but for us i mean russ is right i mean
if he showed a if he showed a vaccine
card that had a penis drawn on it uh
nobody knows the difference yeah that's
fine he'll take it
pretty much i mean nobody's checking to
make sure that the name matches your id
and you know
but you know i don't i'm happy to show
it i'm i'm proud that i got it you know
it's a lot to put on
wait staff i mean it is it's tough
enough they gotta check your id and
worry about that and now you put this on
them
and you know they've been yelled at and
screamed at and called everything so
i'm sure they're over it too i mean i
said i'm not saying it's right well i
mean the other thing too that you know
not many people talk about is i mean the
state of california you know
basically they're doing it because the
state of california has lifted the
restrictions here but you know it was as
one point the most restrictive state in
the entire country and there might be a
tad bit of politics happening
right now
you know but also at the end of the day
you know it does feel like the numbers
are coming down it does feel like this
thing is is starting to go away but
every time that we felt like that it
just comes right back